Hey folks, I just appeared on the Fox
News Channel talking about the
birthright citizenship case involving
Donald Trump's executive order that says
just by virtue of being born in America
doesn't make you a citizen. And why is
that? Oh, I don't know. Maybe because
the text of the 14th amendment to the US
Constitution specifically says there are
two conditions, two conditions that must
be satisfied. One, you're born in the
United States and you must be subject to
the jurisdiction thereof, which means
you have to be loyal and your parents
have to be loyal to America, i.e. you
can't be here illegally or temporarily
here at that point. You would be loyal
to your home country. So, let's show my
Fox News clip and discuss it when we
come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox Adon, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Barn, and
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you. 2025
and 2026 Gun Newsies Awards. All right,
so before I show you this 5minute clip
of my appearance on Fox News. I know
some of you uh don't always catch it. So
that's why I'll play it occasionally
just to show you an occasional Fox News
clip uh where I talk about things. But
this is a big deal because I think that
the left and the mainstream media will
not tell you the truth when it comes to
the 14th amendment that you cannot just
be born in the United States to be an
American citizen. You also and your
parents have to be uh loyal to the
United States in the sense that you're
not loyal to a foreign government. And
if you're an illegal alien in the United
States, you're a citizen of another
country and that child is a citizen of
that country, not of the United States.
But of course, because there's been no
ability for people to challenge this in
court because no one's had standing
other than the people that benefited
from this policy. Until Donald Trump's
executive order that raised the issue in
a legal sense, there was no ability for
people to argue to the Supreme Court
that indeed the 14th Amendment has two
parts to it. One born in the United
States, two subject to the jurisdiction
thereof. And what is subject to the
jurisdiction mean? that was not
available to the Supreme Court for many,
many, many decades because of course the
government went along with this because
they want to replace Americans with
people that are frankly not Americans
and much more willing to give up their
rights because they have no historical
connection to the Bill of Rights, to the
founding fathers, and to what it means
to be an American. So before I play this
clip, I just want to remind you here's
the text of the 14th Amendment. Don't
forget what the text says because the
text again creates two conditions that
must be satisfied, not just being
plopped out on American soil. Check it
out. The 14th Amendment says, quote,
"All persons born in the United States
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof
are citizens of the United States and of
the state wherein they reside." Notice
again two things. All persons born in
the United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States. So the question is, what
exactly does subject to the jurisdiction
mean? Well, we know what it means
because it was really a cotification of
the critical language from the 1866
Civil Rights Act enacted by Congress.
Remember, the 14th Amendment was adopted
in 1868 to make sure that the freed
African-American slaves could not lose
their citizenship moving forward. And
basically what the 14th amendment in
1868 did was it sort of reiterated in a
constitutional sense the highest law of
the land. The congressional statute
enacted two years earlier in 1866 known
as the Civil Rights Act of 1866. And the
critical language there refers to people
being born in the United States and not
loyal to a foreign country. Here's the
critical language from the Civil Rights
Act of 1866, which the 14th Amendment
codified as a constitutional amendment
that all persons born in the United
States and not subject to any foreign
power. Did you see that Civil Rights Act
1866, two years before the 14th
Amendment, it says that all persons born
in the United States and not subject to
any foreign power are citizens. So the
key is loyalty. It's not just being born
in America. is being born in America and
having the loyalty and allegiance to the
United States and not to another
country. But if you break into the
country from Venezuela, from Mexico,
from China, or you come here illegally
or some other game game and your parents
are not loyal to the United States in
that they're citizens of another
country. You're not a citizen of the
United States. Being born here is not
enough. And of course we know this has
been entirely abused where Peter
Schwitzer has reported that you have
literally members senior officials of
the Chinese Communist Party coming to
America giving birth to a child who
becomes a US citizen who 18 years later
gets to vote in our elections. Not to
mention all the welfare benefits they
get and they serve as anchor babies to
tie in and bring family members over
from foreign countries under the family
reunification laws. It's absurd.
Nevertheless, here is what I said on Fox
News. Take a look at it and tell me what
you think about it when we come right
back.
>> The United States Supreme Court is set
to hear arguments this week in a major
case on birthright citizenship. Some
Trump cabinet members are expected to be
in the courtroom on Wednesday as
justices weigh who can be granted
citizen citizenship under the
Constitution. If you're born here, are
you automatically a citizen? It's one of
the highest profile cases of this term.
Let's bring in Mark Smith, a
constitutional attorney and a member of
the Supreme Court bar. Are you making
any predictions, Mark, about how the
Supreme Court will will see this case
and rule on it? I think there's an
excellent chance this is going to be the
vict v biggest victory of Donald Trump's
career as a politician, frankly, to
actually fix a constitutional wrong that
has been a wrong for over a hundred
years. largely because no one has had
standing to sue over it until Donald
Trump's brilliant move to enact this
executive order which finally finally
gave rise to the opportunity to get this
issue before the US Supreme Court. Up
until that time, people did not have
standing to sue because the only people
that sort of got directly impacted by
this. If you're born in the America,
you're automatically American citizen.
They were beneficiaries. So, they
obviously were not going to sue over
this. And now because of Donald Trump,
we're in front of the Supreme Court and
hopefully we're going to get a good
outcome in favor of the Constitution.
>> Tom Dupri was on Fox News Sunday earlier
today. He had this to say about how he
sees the case. Listen.
>> Perth bright citizenship, like it or
not, is enshrined in the Constitution.
So I do think that the administration is
going to have a bit of an uphill battle.
But I will say this, having read the
briefs, looked at what the
administration is arguing, they have
presented a much stronger, more
compelling argument against birthright
citizenship than I had thought coming
into this. I don't know that it's going
to be enough to get five votes in their
favor, but they've made it a close case.
>> Wasn't birthright citizenship originally
uh supposed to help those who were
slaves or children of slaves be
recognized as US citizens?
That's right, John. The reality is that
after the Civil War, the United States
adopted the 14th Amendment. In the 14th
Amendment's text, literally in the text,
John, there's two components that have
to be satisfied for you to be a citizen.
The first is, yes, you have to be born
in the United States, physically born in
the United States. That's step one. But
that's not the only step. You also have
to be what's known as subject to the
jurisdiction thereof. That is the text
of the 14th amendment that the left in
America likes to pretend is nothing more
than a ink block. But the reality is
that subject to the jurisdiction
thereof, John, is very important because
what it says is if you're born, you have
to be born in the United States and you
have to be loyal to the United States,
which means you're not loyal to a
foreign power. Now, if you're the child
of illegal aliens or if your parents
bring you here on a holiday and you're
born here while your parents intend to
go back to China, let's say, you're not
loyal to the United States as understood
by the law. you're beholden to another
foreign country. And that is going way
all the way back, which by the way is
why Native Americans were not citizens
under the 14th amendment. It required a
change in the statutory law in the 20th
century, John, to make Native Americans
uh lawful US citizens because although
they were in the United States at the
time of the uh 1868 14th amendment, they
were not loyal to the United States
because they were loyal to their
respective tribes. Jonathan Turley is a
Fox News contributor, also George
Washington University law professor.
Here's how he sees the argument.
When the 14th Amendment was drafted,
some of the drafters said explicitly
that it does not allow for birthright
citizenship. The problem are these six
words, this clause put in the middle of
an otherwise clear sentence. But the key
is that those words were not in that
sentence in the original draft. They
were intentionally inserted. So you
can't just treat them as superfluous.
That was inserted for a reason. And I
think that there are compelling
arguments on both sides here.
>> So he seems to say that the the drafters
of the 14th amendment made it pretty
clear.
>> Well, I think it's even clearer that in
favor of Donald Trump because in 1866,
John, there was something called the
Civil Rights Act passed by Congress. In
it, it says to be a US citizen, you have
to be born in the United States and you
cannot be beholden to a foreign power.
After that law was passed, Congress
realized that another Congress could
come down the pike and change the law,
basically making African-American,
former African-American slaves no longer
citizens. So to make sure that did not
happen, they decided to take that Civil
Rights Act of 1866 and enshrine it in
the Constitution. And that is what the
14th amendment became. Which is why the
phrase subject to the jurisdiction
thereof is essentially embraced or comes
out of that civil rights act of 1866
that literally says you cannot be
subject to a foreign power. It all turns
on are you and your parents loyal to the
United States. And if you're just
passing through on the way to Hawaii for
fun or you're broke into the country
illegally, that does not make you loyal
to the United States and therefore
you're not subject to the jurisdiction
of the United States. and thus you're
not a citizen under the text of the 14th
amendment. And I think that's what the
Supreme Court's going to say. And the
only reason, John, that we haven't said
it before is because there's never been
an opportunity to get in front of the
courts because no one had standing to
raise these kinds of arguments until
now.
>> Jonathan Turley says that virtually no
nation in Europe allows birthright
citizenship. Are you aware of any
country in the world that does aside
from ours?
>> No, of course not. Look, the most
valuable asset on the planet, period, is
becoming a United States citizen. You
will get to be a citizen of the greatest
country that has ever existed in
mankind's history. Right? That's the
reality of it. So, to think that you
would hand these out just because you
happen to be born here because your
parents broke into the country is simply
absurd. You know, US citizenship is a
lot more than just taking free candy at
the doctor's office. It requires a lot
more than that. Specifically, it
requires loyalty to the country. this is
your home and it can't just be that your
parents are passing through illegally or
otherwise and you happen to get born
here. Uh that is simply not enough to
give you US citizenship and the text of
the 14th Amendment sort of proves that
out as does the history. We'll see what
the Supreme Court decides. It's going to
be a fascinating week and a fascinating
term. Mark Smith, thank you.
>> All right, folks. I hope this clarifies
this birthright citizenship debate. I
really think it's important for you to
understand this because again there is
no good reason I'm sorry there is no
good reason for Americans who support
the right to keep and bear arms and our
bill of rights to bring in millions of
people from foreign cultures who have
zero connection to the history tradition
and experiences of Americans including
the recognition and lived experience of
having private gun ownership in a
self-defense Hey, you cannot bring in
people from cultures that have zero
experience with private gun ownership,
that have zero experience with good guys
with guns and zero experience with guns
being used for self-defense. You can't
bring them in from cultures where the
only people with guns are corrupt
government officials, tyrannical
government officials, or cartel members,
terrorists, and criminals. So, when they
come to the United States, they're going
to be anti-gun. I'm sorry. And they're
anti-Republican. They're pro-democrat
because of all the welfare benefits and
all the game games get played there. We
don't need to blavorver the point. I
understand why it's good for the
immigrants, but I don't care. Even if
their mother Teresa, as far as I'm
concerned, they do not have the
experience of being an American.
Bringing them into the United States, to
vote in our elections, and to replace
Americans is a terrible idea. if you
support the fundamental right to keep
and bear arms and all the other things
that go along with being an American
citizen as understood by the founding
fathers. That is why the Democratic
party are literally fighting tooth and
nail even to prevent criminal violent
aliens from being deported because they
understand that that foreignb born class
are their constituents. And that's why
when you have 1.2 2 million foreignb
born individuals in Virginia alone. And
then you ask, why did Virginia flip in
favor of all this gun control nonsense
and all this other terrible
anti-American stuff? Well, 1.2 million
foreignb born individuals in Virginia
alone probably has something to do with
it because we know they overwhelmingly
vote for the Democrats because that's
where the money comes from. I understand
where their point of view is, but what's
in it for America? And here's further
evidence of that. Anyway, hope this
helped clarify some of these issues.
Make sure you follow me over there on
X4Box. Don't forget to subscribe both
YouTube and Rumble. And I'll talk to you
all again real soon here at the four
boxes. Orders up. Table 2 A.